we don't actually have any evidence that
life exists elsewhere at this point I
would say it's a faith-based question I
think physicists have somewhat of with
bias that everything is kind of simple
and then they think life is really
really difficult so it it has to be rare
in some sense I agree that this is
something which we should investigate
it's one of those things where the
payoff could be so huge that it would be
stupid not to look at it right another
topic that I get a lot of questions
about a lot of my fans listening and
watching you um will want to know
something you don't really talk that
much about um You probably have a video
about it we'll get to your video uh over
and your your catalog in in a in a bit
but uh and that's aliens uh which which
are in the news almost every day now uh
ranging from you know people like past
guest Tom Delong you know claiming he
has uh recovered uh you know a portions
of an alien spaceship when he came on my
podcast uh which was quite uh quite
interesting to to go down the rabbit
Hall with him and find actually he can't
verify exactly that he's owned it anyway
uh but he is I give him credit he
brought a lot of this you know he was a
musician for this band Blink 182 he
lives in San Diego great guy fun guy but
you know he kind of got this into the
attention of the media uh about five six
years ago and now it's risen all the way
up to my friend and uh and colleague and
and president of the Simons Foundation
uh Professor David spurgle and uh David
is now co-leading this NASA panel
commissioned by uh the the the chief
administrator on down to investigate the
role of what they call UAP unidentified
areial phenomena but that could include
UFOs objects it could include evidence
and data uh of course I've had on Avi
lobe and and other people uh as well but
I want to I haven't asked you about this
um where do you come down do you do you
believe that there are uh you know
credible uh bits of evidence suggesting
that Earth well first of all that aliens
exist uh other life forms exist let's
start there do you think life exists
outside of the earth and is that a
scientific question or is it a
faith-based question well we we don't
actually have any evidence that life
exists elsewhere so um at this point I
would say it's a faith-based question um
so if you want to know what I believe I
believe the answer is yes that's mostly
because I I think that it it isn't as
difficult to create complex complexity
um as phys like to think uh I think
businesses have somewhat of a bias that
everything is kind of simple and then
they think life is really really
difficult so it has to be rare in some
sense um uh I think that's not correct
uh but of course I don't know now if
you're asking about any particular type
of evidence I have to admit I I haven't
followed this at all personally I
haven't encountered any particularly um
you know convincing evidence um but yeah
I hav't really looked into it now are
you in the camp or perhaps not in the
camp of those like our mutual friend
Eric Weinstein uh who suggests things
such as uh the fact that we should
devote some substantial resources to the
investigation of the phenomenon because
it might reveal new physics that could
then be used to solve many predicaments
that we have on Earth namely how do we
get off the Earth without you know he
says you know putting chemical oxidants
inside of a phallic shaped tube and
shooting it to Mars as as our friend
Elon wants to do uh but would you say
that if if we did find evidence of not
not just alien life like slime mold on
you know on Proxima centuri B but if we
found technological intelligent life
that that would open up a new portal
into physics uh that we would otherwise
be ignorant to do you think that's even
a conceivable
Prospect for Humanity well it's
certainly conceivable in the sense that
it's I can imagine it um if the question
is How likely is it I have no idea I
mean I I agree that this is something
which we should investigate now if if I
think what we said was we should invest
significant resources of course it
brings up the question like how
significant right what what amounts are
we talking about uh I'm not really in
the position to make that kind of
judgment uh as I said I haven't really
followed it I would I would generally
agree yeah I mean it's a really
important thing it's one of those things
where the payoff could be so
huge that it would be stupid not to look
at it right yeah I think that that's
absolutely true uh as well and yet you
know the question of the the level of um
of fervor uh about it is kind of
unmatched by the evidence and I want to
run an argument by you that I've used on
other scientists that are you know you
know more involved with this um phen you
know phenomena and even the the concept
of it uh and that's this concept called
panspermia which was originally it
sounds dirty but it's not don't worry we
won't get our YouTube demonetized uh but
the uh the concept was that life on
Earth it doesn't solve the origin of
Life problem but it solves the origin of
life on Earth problem and that's by
these little objects called meteorites
by the way you can get your own
meteorite if you subscribe to my mailing
list Brian king.com /list and if you
subscribe to sabina's mailing list maybe
she'll send you like a theory or she'll
she'll she'll tell you that you're full
of gobbledygook uh but you should
subscribe to that Sabina Hassen Felder
has a wonderful mailing list we'll put
links to that below but um but the
theory of panspermia posits that life on
Earth originated because uh objects like
these meteorites had chemical uh life uh
exist uh molecules or precursors to life
or even life itself and they can survive
and they can land on on the earth and
then that causes darwinian Evolution to
sprout right so that's the theory but I
invert that argument and I say if that's
true then we should see life on uh on
Europa or on Titan or on some other moon
or or asteroid or something because this
we've had life on Earth for four billion
years uh it's it's only took a couple
hundred million years for life to get
kicked off and often Earth gets hit by
metor meteoroids and those blast off
these same chunks of Earth including
life and they be floating around the
solar system for literally billions of
years and some of them should have do
land on Mars we know that they've landed
on Mars because we have stuff from Mars
that land on Earth anyway Sab this is a
long-winded question but do you believe
that the lack of evidence of life from
Earth on another body in our solar
system can provide some basian prior on
the existence or the ability for
panspermia to take place in other words
for life to get uh spread throughout the
cosmos as soon as it gets created well
of course in principle yes but we don't
have a terrible lot of evidence about uh
you know M microbial life on other
planets like we've just about made it to
Mars or maybe to the moon but what what
do we know about the other planets and
then there's this whole issue about the
habitable zone right if you're only
looking at planet in the habitable
zone then this planet is it right so uh
I'm I'm not sure how useful this
evidence is